JEWEL LANGEVINE: Hello, my
name is Jewel Langevine,
and today I am going to take you
through my journey of becoming
Google Cloud Certified.
I'll give you an
introduction to who I am,
a bit about my
certification journey,
the impact it has
had on my career,
and then leave you
with some takeaways.
So let's get started
with an introduction.
My name is Jewel, and I
am a solution engineer
at Google Cloud.
I am currently a Google Cloud
Certified professional data
engineer, associate
cloud engineer,
and professional
cloud architect.
I'm really, really
happy to be here today
to share my story with you.
It's interesting to think
of my journey as a three
by three by three.
Three countries, three states,
and three certifications.
I was born in Guyana
in South America.
I grew up in the
Bahamas, and in the USA,
I have lived in Texas
and New York City
before eventually moving to
California for my current role.
I have always been an
inquisitive person since birth.
For example, in
Guyana, my father
used to buy mint candies
before church every week
and I used to divvy them
up amongst my family
to make sure that we
all had the same amount.
Over the years, that natural
instinct for data and analysis
has led me to grow into a
thoughtful and analytical
technology professional, and I'm
really grateful to be in a role
here at Google that
allows me to own in
on and grow those skills.
Now, let's look at my
certification story.
I have bucketed today's story
into three major milestones
in my journey.
They are moving to New York
City, growing my network,
and deciding to move
forward to become certified.
I have been a user
of Google Cloud tools
for about three
and half years now,
and I have been working in
the cloud space for about that
long as well.
My experience really
started when I first
moved to New York City.
I moved there for a
marketing engineering program
in the advertising
technology space,
and after that program ended, I
got a job as a platform analyst
at a small startup.
And I'm really
grateful for that role.
That's actually where
I started to get
my hands on GCP experience.
My first step into
Google Cloud was
with BigQuery and
the client interface,
and about a month and a half
after I joined the team,
our company was actually
acquired by another company
and that is where
I was introduced
to how to work in multi
cloud environments
since the company that
acquired us was actually
working with another cloud
service provider at that time.
So I learned how to integrate
and how to migrate data
across cloud services, and as I
continued to grow in my career,
I eventually became
a consultant where
I was introduced to the
world of cloud architecture
and how to use various
Google Cloud tools to build
a full solution, then
document that solution
with technical documentation.
All of this was
really valuable to me
and it all started with
my move to New York City.
I not only got hands on
Google Cloud experience,
but I got broad cloud
experience as well.
The takeaway that
I want to note here
is don't be afraid to change.
Have the confidence to
take the first step.
Now, moving on to my network.
I highly, highly
recommend that you
seek out and nurture
healthy opportunities
to build your network.
This is what really helped
me expand my confidence
as a technology professional.
I grew my network through
meetups, industry events,
and organizations such as the
Houston Google Developers Group
which partnered with
Women Techmakers for some
of the events I attended.
And meetups in New York
City such as the TechYes!
Diversity in Tech Meetup,
along with the Houston GCP user
group.
Check out your
local tech community
to see what's available to you.
If there aren't any
or many options,
I encourage you to create one.
Now, I just shared
with you that I
did have quite a bit
of hands-on experience
on the Google Cloud platform.
However, what I have come to
realize over the past year
or so is that I was moreso
thinking of myself as someone
who knew how to use a
tool rather than someone
who was a professional
in the cloud industry.
And when that thinking
really turned around
was joining the Google
Cloud Learning Workshop,
which is one of
Google's diversity,
equity, and
inclusion initiatives
to bring more perspectives
into the cloud industry.
One of my favorite
parts of the workshop
was meeting with
other professionals
with varying years of experience
and varying levels of expertise
in the cloud space.
This really helped to
broaden my horizons
and deepen my understanding
of the use of GCP
across the use cases.
I realized that some of the
professionals in the room
had been working on technical
infrastructure concepts
before the concept
of cloud computing
was even widely known.
And I also realized that there
were professionals in the room,
like myself, who were learning
about technical infrastructure
concepts through cloud computing
rather than the other way
around.
And what I noticed in
conversations with my cohort
is that I was actually able to
share knowledge and ideas as
if I had been working in this
industry for five or ten years,
and my confidence
grew dramatically
as I realized that I really
did know what I was talking
about as a result of
my hands-on experience
in this new industry.
When you get that
boost of confidence,
you continue to grow it, and
that's exactly what I did.
This is and really was a
great turning point for me
as I continue to grow as
a leader and a technology
professional.
Since being able to speak
clearly and with confidence
is an important trait of
being in a leadership role.
My takeaway for you here
is to identify your goals
and surround yourself
with others who have
achieved something similar--
or who have achieved something
bigger than themselves--
and begin to network with them.
You might be amazed at how that
can transform your mindset as
well.
So now, with all that
being said and done,
as I continue to grow
in my confidence,
I was also introduced to the
world of certification itself.
Previously, I had seen
certification as something
that someone with many more
years of experience than I had
would go for, and maybe I could
go for in a few years as well.
However, after my experience
in the learning workshop,
I began to realize that
certification could
be the right route for me.
And I also saw it as
a great achievement
to really solidify
my cloud expertise.
And when it comes to the
action of taking the exam,
this is a wonderful story
that I'm proud of as well.
I took the Associate Cloud
Engineer exam in August
and did not pass.
It honestly was
so disappointing,
because I was looking forward
to passing it as many of us
do when we take exams.
So I did take some time
to be disappointed,
and then I decided to move on.
I took a look at the
areas in the exam
that I felt the most
uncomfortable with
and then I also explored
exam topics in general
across the Google
Cloud certifications.
And throughout
that review period,
after re-evaluating
my skills, I realized
that the data engineering
certification was potentially
the right route for me,
especially since I was coming
from the world of data and I had
hands-on experience with cloud
technologies in the data space.
So I took the data
engineering exam and passed.
I was so excited.
It was actually
three weeks after I
had failed the Associate
Cloud Engineer exam
and I was happy and
proud of myself.
Fast forward to February of this
year when after months of study
and months of additional
practice across the Google
Cloud platform tools,
I was able to pass
both the professional
Cloud Architect's
exam and the Associate Cloud
Engineer exam on the same day.
My takeaway for you
here is to stay focused
and know how you learn
best and let that lead how
you study for the
certification exams
if certification is
one of your goals.
Becoming Google Cloud Certified
had an important impact
on my career.
This impact included
immediate career benefits,
long term professional
gains, and new opportunities
for mentorship.
In terms of immediate
career benefits
in the role that I was in at
the time, becoming certified
opened doors for me to attend a
really cool industry conference
on behalf of my
employer at that time.
I felt like it was a really cool
reward and a great opportunity
for me, and it also
provided me with more
of a voice in the
product engagement
that I was in at that time
Now, onto long-term
professional gains.
A big one has been the
opportunity to work at Google.
This has been a dream of mine
and a goal of mine for a while.
At Google, I am a
solution engineer
on a team called the Cloud
Solution Studio, and what we do
is really, really cool.
I, along with my
team, build assets
for our sales teams which
demonstrate Google Cloud
solutions across use cases.
In my role, I have
the opportunity
to build on my Google Cloud
certifications and knowledge
to use storytelling, design
thinking, and project
management skills to bring
our solutions to life.
I have been at Google
for over six months now
and it's been really great.
I got involved in the
Black Googler Network
where I have a great buddy
who has given me advice
and has also just been a great
friend, including giving me
recommendations for
hairdressers which
has been really useful since
I'm new to the Bay Area.
I have also been pretty active
in Google's outreach efforts,
including our Grow with
Google initiative, giving back
to the Google Cloud
Learning workshop,
and other certification
outreach efforts.
And last but not least,
getting certified
has opened doors to mentorship.
As part of the
learning workshop,
I met someone who is actually
still one of my mentors
to this day.
I reached out to her and
we stayed in contact,
and now that I am
here at Google,
I am able to meet with
her on a regular basis
and talk about how I am
growing as a professional.
I really do value her advice and
her input into the growth areas
that we discuss.
Now, before we
wrap up, I do want
to share some takeaways that I
think would be valuable for you
no matter where you
are on your journey
and where you are in your
certification path, as well.
The first is to look
at the growth goals
that you have set for yourself
and have the confidence
to take the first step.
It can always feel
daunting to do this.
In my case, it was
daunting to look
at others who were
certified and think, well,
I can be certified too.
Yet it required me to
take the first step.
For me, that looked like being
part of the learning workshop,
taking courses and studying
diligently, and even taking
the first step of registering
to take the exams.
I encourage you to also
have the confidence
to take the first step
and believe in yourself.
I would also recommend that you
proactively build your network.
Seek out opportunities to learn
from, partner with, and help
those who have achieved things
similar to the goals you
have set for yourself.
Also consider
seeking out guidance
from those who have achieved
things bigger than themselves.
This will help you
to better understand
what it takes to get
where you need to be
and it will help
with accountability
along your journey.
It can be really easy to make
goals and then not follow up.
If you have put certification as
a professional or even personal
goal for yourself,
then go for it.
Proactively build your
network and make sure
that you have a level
of accountability.
And consider giving back by
being a mentor to someone else,
especially after
you're certified.
Last but not least, discover
your unique approach.
This can take on
numerous meanings.
In the certification
space, I would
say to discover the
way you learn best
and craft your study
plan around that.
As an example from
my end, I realized
that I learn best by
testing myself, getting
hands-on experience, and being
able to tie that experience
to the concepts.
So, knowing this, I crafted
my personal study plans
around those principles.
I recommend that you take
a look at your experiences
as a learner and see the ways
that you have learned best,
then take that and
create a personal study
plan for yourself.
Make sure you're being
true to yourself.
Thank you so much for your time.
I really appreciate
the opportunity
to share my story
with you and hopefully
being able to inspire you
to craft a story of your own
that you can be proud of.
Be sure to check
out the appendix
of this deck for additional
certification resources.
Have a great day, and
perhaps I will see you soon.